it was chaos as I got off the elevator I
was coming back on duty as a resident
physician to cover the labor and
delivery unit and all I could see was a
swarm of doctors and nurses hovering
over a patient in the labor room they
were all desperately trying to save a
woman's life the patient was in shock
she had delivered a healthy baby boy
a few hours before I arrived suddenly
she collapsed became unresponsive and
had profuse uterine bleeding by the time
I got to the room there were multiple
doctors and nurses and the patient was
lifeless the resuscitation team tried to
bring her back to life but despite
everyone's best efforts she died what I
remember most about that day was the
father's piercing cry it went through my
heart and the heart of everyone on that
floor this was supposed to be the
happiest day of his life but instead it
turned out to be the worst day I wish I
could say this tragedy was an isolated
incident but sadly that's not the case
every year in the United States
somewhere between 700 and 900 women die
from a pregnancy related cause the
shocking part of this story is that our
maternal mortality rate is actually
higher than all other high-income
countries and our rates are far worse
for women of color our rate of maternal
mortality actually increased over the
last decade while other countries reduce
their rates and the biggest paradox of
all we spend more on health care than
any other country in the world well
around the same time in residency that
this new mother lost her life I became a
mother myself and even with all of my
background and training in the field I
was taken aback by how little attention
was paid to delivering high quality
maternal health care and I thought about
what that meant not just for myself but
for so many other women
maybe it's because my dad was a civil
rights attorney and my parents were
socially conscious and demanded that we
stand up for what we believe in or the
fact that my parents were born in
Jamaica came to the United States and
were able to realize the American dream
or maybe it was my residency training
where I saw firsthand how poorly so many
low-income women of color were treated
by our healthcare system for whatever
the reason I felt a responsibility to
stand up not just for myself but for all
women and especially those marginalized
by our healthcare system and I decided
to focus my career on improving maternal
health care so what's killing mothers
cardiovascular disease hemorrhage high
blood pressure causing seizures and
strokes blood clots and infection are
some of the major causes of maternal
mortality in this country but a maternal
death is only the tip of the iceberg for
every death over a hundred women suffer
a severe complication related to
pregnancy and childbirth resulting in
over 60,000 women every year having one
of these events these complications
called severe maternal morbidity are on
the rise in the United States and
they're life-altering
it's estimated that somewhere between
1.5 and 2% of the 4 million deliveries
that occur every year in this country
are associated with one of these events
that is five or six women every hour
having a blood clot a seizure a stroke
receiving a blood transfusion having end
organ damage such as kidney failure or
some other tragic event now the part of
this story that's frankly unforgivable
is the fact that 60% of these deaths and
severe complications are thought to be
preventable when I say 60 percent are
preventable I mean there are concrete
steps and standard procedures that we
could implement that could prevent these
bad outcomes from occurring and save
women's life and it doesn't require
fancy new technology we just have to
apply what we know and ensure equal
standards between hospitals
for example if a pregnant woman in labor
has really high blood pressure and we
treat her with the right
antihypertensive medication in a timely
fashion we can prevent stroke if we
accurately track blood loss during
delivery we can detect a hemorrhage
sooner and save a woman's life we could
actually lower the rates of these
catastrophic events tomorrow but it
requires that we value the quality of
care we deliver to pregnant women before
during and after pregnancy if we raise
quality of care universally to what is
supposed to be the standard we could
bring the rates of these deaths and
severe complications way down well there
is some good news there are some success
stories there are some places that have
actually adopted these standards and
it's really making a difference a few
years ago the American College of
Obstetricians and Gynaecologists joined
forces with other health care
organizations researchers like myself
and community organizations they wanted
to implement standard care practices in
hospitals and health systems throughout
the country and the vehicle they're
using is a program called the Alliance
for innovation and maternal health the
aim program their goal is to lower
maternal mortality and severe maternal
morbidity rates through quality and
safety initiatives across the country
the group has developed a number of
safety bundles that target some of the
most preventable causes of a maternal
death the aim program currently has the
potential to reach over 50% of u.s. bers
so what's in a safety bundle
evidence-based practices protocols
procedures medications equipment and
other items targeting these conditions
let's take the example of a hemorrhage
bundle for a hemorrhage you need a cart
that has everything a doctor or nurse
might need an emergency an IV line and
oxygen mask medications checklist other
equipment then you need something to
measure blood loss sponges and pads and
instead of just eyeballing it the
doctors and nurses collect these sponges
and pads and either wave them or use
newer technology to accurately assess
how much
blood has been lost the hemorrhage
bundle also includes crises protocols
for massive transfusions and regular
trainings and drills now California has
been a leader in the use of these types
of bundles and that's why California saw
a 21 percent reduction in near death
from hemorrhage among hospitals that
implemented this bundle in the first
year yet the use of these bundles across
the country is spotty you're missing
just like the fact that the use of
evidence-based practices and the
emphasis on safety differs from one
hospital to the next quality of care
differs in quality of care differs
greatly for women of color in the United
States black women who deliver in this
country are three to four times more
likely to suffer a pregnancy related
deaths than our white women this
statistic is true for all black women
who deliver in this country whether they
were born in the United States or born
in another country many want to think
that income differences drive these
disparities but it goes beyond class a
black woman with a college education is
nearly twice as likely to die as
compared to a white woman with less than
a high school education and she is two
to three times more likely to suffer a
severe pregnancy complication with her
delivery now I was always taught to
think that education was our salvation
but in this case it's simply not true
this black/white disparity is the
largest disparity among all population
perinatal health measures according to
the CDC and these disparities are even
more pronounced in some of our cities
for example in New York City a black
woman is eight to twelve times more
likely to die from a pregnancy related
cause than as a white woman now I think
many of you are probably familiar with
the heart-wrenching story of dr. chillon
Irving a CDC epidemiologist who died
following childbirth her story was
reported in ProPublica in NPR a little
less than a year ago and recently I was
at a conference and I had the privilege
of hearing her mother speak she brought
the entire audience to tears
shal owned was a brilliant
epidemiologist committed to studying
racial and ethnic disparities in health
she was 36 years old this was her first
baby and she was african-american
now shallow did have a complicated
pregnancy but she delivered a healthy
baby girl and was discharged from the
hospital three weeks later she died from
complications of high blood pressure
shal own was seen four or five times by
health care professionals in those three
weeks she was not listened to
and the severity of her condition was
not recognized
now she alone story is just one of many
stories about racial and ethnic
disparities in health and health care in
the United States and there's a growing
recognition that the social determinants
of health such as racism poverty
education segregated housing contribute
to these disparities but Shiell own
story highlights an additional
underlying cause quality of care lack of
standards in postpartum care shalom was
seen multiple times by clinicians in
those three weeks and she still died
quality of care in the setting of
childbirth is an underlying cause of
racial and ethnic disparities and
maternal mortality and severe maternal
morbidity in the United States and it's
something we can address now research by
our team and others has documented that
for a variety of reasons black women
tend to deliver in a specific set of
hospitals and those hospitals often have
worse outcomes for both black and white
women regardless of patient risk factors
this is true over all in the United
States we're about three-quarters of all
black women deliver in a specific set of
hospitals while less than one-fifth of
white women deliver in those same
hospitals in New York City a woman's
risk of having a life-threatening
complication during delivery can be six
times higher in one Hospital than
another not surprisingly black women are
more likely to deliver in hospitals with
worse outcomes in fact differences in
delivery Hospital explained nearly one
half of the black/white disparity
while we must address social
determinants of health if we're ever
going to truly have equitable health
care in this country many of these are
deep-seated and they will take some time
to resolve in the meantime we can tackle
quality of care providing high quality
care across the care continuum means
providing access to safe and reliable
contraception throughout women's
reproductive lives before pregnancy it
means providing preconception care so we
can manage chronic illness and optimize
health during pregnancy it includes high
quality prenatal and delivery care so we
can produce healthy moms and babies and
finally after pregnancy it includes
postpartum and inner pregnancy care so
we can set mom's up to have a healthy
next baby and a healthy life and it can
literally spell the difference between
life and death as it did in the case of
Maria who checked into the hospital
after having an elevated blood pressure
during a prenatal visit Maria was 40 and
this was her second pregnancy during
Maria's first pregnancy that had
happened two years earlier she also
didn't feel so well in the last few
weeks of her pregnancy and she had a few
elevated blood pressures but nobody
seemed to pay attention they just said
Maria don't worry you'll be fine this is
your first pregnancy you're a little
nervous but it did not end well for
Muriel ass time she seized during labor
well this time her team really listened
they asked smart and probing questions
her doctor counseled her about the
science and symptoms of preeclampsia and
explained that if she was not feeling
well she needed to come in and be seen
and this time Maria came in and her
doctor immediately sent her to the
hospital at the hospital her doctor
ordered urgent lab tests they hooked her
up to multiple different monitors and
paid special attention to her blood
pressure the fetal heart rate tracing
and gave her IV medication to prevent a
seizure and when Maria's blood pressure
got so high at put her at risk first
stroke her doctors and nurses jumped
into action
they repeated her blood pressure in 15
minutes and declared a hypertensive
emergency they gave her the right IV
medication according to the latest
correct protocol
they worked smoothly together as a
coordinated team and successfully
lowered her blood pressure as a result
what could have been a tragedy became a
success story
Maria's dangerous symptoms were
controlled and she delivered a healthy
baby girl and before Maria was
discharged from the hospital
her doctor counseled her again about the
signs and symptoms of preeclampsia the
importance of having her blood pressure
checked and then especially in this
first week postpartum and gave her
education about postpartum health and
what to expect and in the weeks and
months that followed naturally Maria had
follow-up visits with her pediatrician
to check in on her baby's health but
just as important she had follow-up
visits with her OBGYN to check in on her
health her blood pressure and her cares
and concerns as a new mother this is
what high quality care across the care
continuum looks like and this is how it
can look if every pregnant woman in
every community received this kind of
high quality care and deliberative
facilities that utilize standard care
practices our maternal mortality and
severe maternal morbidity rates would
plummet our international ranking would
no longer be an embarrassment but the
truth is we've had decades of
unacceptably high rates of maternal
death and life threatening complications
during delivery and decades of
devastating consequences for moms babies
and Families and we have not been moved
to action the recent media attention on
our poor performance on maternal
mortality has helped the public to
understand high quality maternal health
care is within reach the question is are
we as a society ready to value pregnant
women from every community for my part
I'm doing everything I can to ensure
that when we do we have the tools and
evidence base ready to move forward
thank you
[Applause]